hey guys it's Jan here the figurative
game of chess between katniss everdeen
and President Snow that began back in
The Hunger Games finally comes to an end
in Mockingjay part 2 and what a game
it's been full of socio political
commentary wrapped up in action heuer
crazy costumes and makeup with a wealth
of characters brought to life by an
amiable cast of actors and the person
who's really kept that game on course is
Jennifer Lawrence the first time I
remember seeing her on-screen was in the
indie film Winter's Bone and it was
clear then she had bags of talent and
she's used every drop of that to good
effect in The Hunger Games Movies
showcasing a range of emotions and
skills and Mockingjay part 2 is
certainly no exception of course the
love triangle between Katniss Josh
Hutcherson's Peter and Liam Hemsworth
scale continues with some humorous and
heartfelt moments i guess that triangle
hasn't been my favorite bit of the
movies probably because Gail's character
hasn't always been particularly well
developed in the scripts but when they
do get a chance to shine as they do in
Mockingjay part 2 both Hutchison and
Hemsworth make the most of it as for the
movie supporting cast what can I say but
Wow regardless of the amount of time
they spend on screen in this movie they
are never less and excellent and I
cannot imagine anyone else playing those
characters now Donald Sutherland is once
again outstanding as the delightfully
rotten President Snow Woody Harrelson is
as ever superb as Haymitch Elizabeth
Banks dazzles again as Effie Trinket
Stanley Tucci just is Caesar Flickerman
I love Julian war as a calculating
president coin and mahalo ali as boggs
Jeffrey Wright gives a nicely
understated Turner's BTW sam claflin as
Finnick stands out in some awesome
action scenes jena malone looks like
she's having a blast playing up the
super servic side of Johanna and it's
good to see Natalie Dormer get more to
do this time this sadly Gwendolyn
Christie's role is little more than a
cameo but on the bright side for her
they're still the force awakens to come
this year of all the supporting cast
it's philip seymour hoffman's
performances Plutarch heavensbee that
proves the most emotional tinged as it
is with sadness following the loss of
this supremely talon
and versatile actor indeed is untimely
passing as real resonance two words
spoken by Haymitch late on in the film
Mockingjay part 2 features some
excellent action sequences including a
particularly sticky one above ground and
an extremely claustrophobic and
heart-stopping one set underground which
has shades of aliens and the british
horror movie that is sent about it
shoutouts go to special effects
coordinator steve kremen stunt
coordinator chris o hara visual effects
supervisor adrienne de wet production
designer Phillip Messina and all their
teams for their work both on those
moments and throughout the film although
this is a pretty dark film as well as
the action there is still humor with
some lovely examples especially from
Haymitch Katniss Gale and Johanna oh and
there are a number of core back to the
previous movie to fans of the franchise
by the way I've got to give props to the
makeup department heads V Neil and
Nicoletta score lattice on their team
for a great job including at the very
start of the film some disturbingly
realistic bruising on katniss's neck
after Peters attempt to strangle her at
the end of part 1 on the minus side
there are a few moments or events such a
sign posted a little too heavily for you
not to realize what's going to happen
before it does and at times the movie
sociopolitical commentary can be a
little too on the nose plus for me the
very ending which is sort of an epilogue
felt unnecessary I would have preferred
it if the film would finish a touch
before it did so to sum up the Hunger
Games Mockingjay part 2 brings the world
of Katniss and co2 fitting conclusion
and to quote the great Haymitch I'll say
this for you Katniss you don't
disappoint The Hunger Games Mockingjay
part 2 gets 4 out of 5 flicks now what
are you looking forward to most about
Mockingjay part 2 or if you've seen it
what did you think and who's your
favorite character in The Hunger Games
franchise let me know in the comments
below my next video is going to be
things you probably didn't know about
Mockingjay part 2 and on an annotation
here once it's live and I'm also hoping
to have a review of the new marble TV
series Jessica Jones soon if you liked
this review I really appreciate you
sharing and liking it and do feel free
to subscribe for more of my new
reviews interviews and things you didn't
know videos thanks for watching and see
you next time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
you